this Square and metro station are both
named arsenal after this former
munitions factory which was at the
center of a revolt by Bolshevik
revolutionaries a century ago today many
Ukrainians questioned the legacy of the
Revolution and the communist system that
followed we're seventy years behind the
rest of the world because of communism
Europe is flourishing but we're at a
standstill
all because we took a step backwards
that day I've forgotten about the
revolution even though we celebrated it
every year during Soviet times we were
always herded to rallies and
demonstrations it was the start of
socialism it didn't exist before then
which is why I think it was good it was
a step forward for the world this used
to be the Lenin museum now it's a
memorial to the first Ukrainian People's
Republic it was founded in 1917 when the
Russian Empire was crumbling its leaders
wanted nothing to do with the revolution
in Russia a large part of the history of
the Ukrainian People's Republic was
spent fighting the Russian Empire and
Russian imperialism this strengthened
our sense of who we are as a people and
a nation this historical footage shows
the first days of the fledgling People's
Republic the political turmoil of the
time and the costly war with the
Bolsheviks are only hinted at in these
shaky images when the conflict was over
the Bolsheviks emerged victorious and
Ukraine was incorporated into the Soviet
Union the dream of democracy and
autonomy was over for decades now the
statues of Lenin are gone and Ukraine
wants to shed its communist past by law
pure through Celeste is the grandson of
a former Ukrainian Communist Party
leader
he'd like to see the revolution
officially celebrated in Kiev once again
beautifully bruschetta veloute is
Finnerty the october revolution gave the
world a new form of civilization that is
one thing
second the october revolution created
the state of ukraine it did not exist
before october 1917 that's a view of
history not shared at the museum
historians place a different emphasis on
the events that took place a hundred
years ago society now understands that
the Russian Revolution was just one
event in the reorganization of the
Russian Empire but that it was carried
out under a different flag that of
communism Ukraine was not able to accept
that on any level today the October
Revolution is a distant event for the
people of Kiev they have more pressing
issues on their minds at the end of this
past October hundreds of demonstrators
camped outside Parliament demanding long
overdue reforms in 2017 confronting the
government is considered part of
democracy in contrast to a century ago